hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
targeting prostate cancer stem cells
with T cell immunotherapy I'm Christie
jewel of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
thermo Fisher com let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I would now like to present
today's speaker
Amy Cod for a complete biography on Amy
please see the biography tab at the top
of your screen Amy you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for that introduction hi
everyone I'm Amy I'm a final PhD student
final year PhD student in Cardiff
University I'm in the tissue micro
environment group my supervisors are
Susanna Taavi and Steven man so I'd like
to thank thermo Fisher for sponsoring
this presentation and the cell culture
heroes program as I think it's a really
great opportunity to present my work and
thank you also to lab roots for hosting
so my talk today is about targeting
prostate cancer stem cells by T cell
immunity I'm going to start by giving
you an overview of my talk I'm going to
be talking about each of these elements
today cancer stem cells prostate cancer
and immunotherapy so to introduce cancer
stem cells I want to talk first about
the cancer stem cell theory of cancer
development and then also how cancer
stem cells can be identified which is
not actually the easiest thing
considering the cancer stem cell theory
is not a cut-and-dried a coherent idea
but actually I'll go into that more in a
little bit next I'll be speaking about
prostate cancer as my work on cancer
stem cells has been focused on prostate
cancer it's actually a big area of
interest here in Wales so I'm based in
Cardiff University and also a wider in
the UK and here in Cardiff University we
have really good connections to the
hospitals here for getting samples which
is really lucky then I'll be speaking
about vino therapy which I'm sure at
this stage doesn't actually that much of
an introduction these days as it's very
much in the news and becoming more and
more commonly used in cancer treatment
so I'll be discussing the basis of
cancer immunotherapy which is cancer
immunology and how this was first
proposed so like the interactions
between the immune system and a
developing tumor and then how these
interactions are activated inhibited or
otherwise modified for cancer
immunotherapy as my focus today is on T
cell immunity repiy I'll be discussing
the identification of T cell antigens
which is something that I've done in my
PhD and then I'll be discussing how this
can be applied to cancer stem cells so
identifying cancer stem cell antigens
for therapeutic targeting
so the counter stem cell theory of
cancer this suggests that tumors consist
of a hierarchy of cancer stem cells and
non cancer stem cells and it is only the
cancer stem cells that are sustained
capable of sustaining tumor growth this
is because they are capable of
self-renewal so they're constantly able
to maintain a pool of stem cells that
remains d differentiated and for example
Express the genes associated with
development and stemness what they're
also capable of is dividing to produce
non-stem cancer cells so in the
production of non stem cancer cells this
population the nonsan cancer cells don't
have self renewal capacity and they're
more differentiated although there might
be an intermediate population or like a
gradual decrease in stem like
characteristics but it's likely that
this intermediate population wouldn't be
able to sustain or initiate tumors like
cancer stem cells can so the non stem
cancer cells make up the rest of the
tumor the tumor book and the cancer stem
cells are typically thought to be a very
rare population although this can vary
between cancers and so this feature
isn't really a defining characteristic
so the presence of cancer stem cells
which give rise to non FEM cancer cells
means that there's both a hierarchy and
heterogeneity in the tumor which is also
part of the cancer stem cell hypothesis
this heterogeneity in that the cancer
stem cells and the non SEM cancer cells
have different characteristics I'll be
going into these more in a bit and then
there can be heterogeneity also based on
the acquisition of mutations so
different cancer stem cells could
acquire mutation and pass this down to
their hierarchy there could be more than
one clonal cancer stem cell mutation and
hierarchy and also the non cancer stem
cells being transformed and genetically
unstable may accumulate mutations adding
further heterogeneity so the cancer stem
cell theory also suggests that it's stem
cells are the most susceptible to
carcinogenic transformation as they're
long-lived so in a position to
accumulate mutations which would
otherwise be lost before the initiative
is the animal agency if it was a
differentiated cell it's also suggested
that gene expression signature of cancer
stem cells is more permissive to cancer
development so for example continued
growth instead of programmed death
signals although it is also suggested
that the transition to cancer may have
to activate stem cells from dormancy in
a tissue on the other hand though it's
suggested that these stemless
characteristics could all be gained in
the process of carcinogenesis so an
actual mutation to transform to cancer
would activate a gene signature so it's
possible that more committed progenitor
cells in differentiated cells could
become cancer stem cells or that there's
even a degree of plasticity and that
differentiated cells could gain stem
like characteristics in an established
tumor and this set of characteristics
which is beneficial for the maintenance
of cancer like selective pressure could
select for another cancer stem like
clone so it actually isn't fully agreed
upon which is the predecessor cell to a
cancer stem cell although having these
characteristics in common with stem
cells is what informs identification and
characterization of stem cells so you
might actually see in the literature
different like names used for cancer
stem cells and apps down to a number of
factors firstly the use of stem in the
name might imply the origin of the
cancer stem cell and because like I said
this isn't actually
entirely agreed upon it may not appear
correct to use to call them as a stem
cell a cancer stem cell and then also
the acids we use to identify cancer stem
cells may not be able to capture even
these agreed-upon characteristics of
cancer stem cells in our model so for
example by isolating cancer stem cells
from their niche niche in tissue this
may disrupt the hierarchy and resulting
in them behaving differently in in our
experimental conditions and it's also
been suggested that the cells which
initiate a tumor so these might be
referred to as tumor initiating cells
that these cells might just be the best
survivors of an experimental
manipulation rather than the actual self
same cells as the cancer stem cells of
the star found in the tissue so this is
actually a real challenge in this area
to have agreement on what Isis for
cancer stem cells actually demonstrate
what what we believe we're showing from
an assay and how this effect identifying
cancer stem cells for therapeutic
purposes so for a certain amount of
clarity in this talk I'm going to refer
to cancer stem cells by functional
definition that the cancer stem cells
are a distinct population of cells in
tumors possessing them as
characteristics and this recent review
actually gives a really good detailed
commentary on some of these features so
I do think it's important as well to
contextualize these in the tumor
microenvironment the cancer stem cell
features versus kind of the overall
cancer features because we could
remember really that some of these
features are common to non stem cancer
cells like how the tumor
microenvironment is generally
immunosuppressive in most types of
cancer and obviously while some of this
contribution is so some of this
contribution has to be from the non
cancer stem cells if these are in the
majority as I said the cancer stem cells
are typically relatively rare and so the
cancer stem cell but anyway so they cut
the non stem cancer cells presumably
actually contribute a certain amount of
these sort of survival and growth cues
and you know suppression ability to
resist they may actually help promote
and interact with the cancer stem cell
niche but the cancer stem cell theory
was proposed to
why cancer relapse occurs so it suggests
that some cancers some cells just any
kind of cells these must not be
eradicated by cancer treatment and this
results in regrowth of a tumor so there
are just surviving cells which are
failed to be eradicated by a treatment
and these cells presumably have some
particular characteristics to allow them
to resist treatment as I suggested in
the diagram there and if it is the stem
cell that becomes transformed to develop
a tumor then also like stem cells must
be able to evade immuno surveillance so
evasion must be a characteristic as well
as therapeutic resistance so to identify
cancer stem cells we take from what is
known about just healthy ordinary stem
cells in other words the surface and
functional markers of these cells these
markers have been identified for a lot
of cancers and this list I'm sure is not
exhaustive you can see that there are a
lot of cancer stem cell markers which
have been identified for hematological
and solid cancers some markers are
common to a couple different type of
cancers so I just highlighted the
functional markers in red to distinguish
them the functional markers are odd
hydrogenase and the atp-binding cassette
so known as the ABC transporter family
of proteins these functional markers are
known by that name because they play a
specific role in stem cell
characteristic for example the ABC
transporter family have a flux of
molecules for example chemotherapy drugs
this is actually a functional protective
role in the maintenance of the stem cell
phenotype so the stem cell function of
some of the other markers the other
surface markers may not actually be
entirely known and it's also clear that
some of these proteins have different
roles in different cells so stem or non
stem cells because they are actually
widely expressed in the body so for
example cd44 there
so as I said identifying cancer stem
cells is based on what we know about
stem cells so it's probably not coming
as too much of a surprise to know that
the first country stem cells were
identified in hematological countries
because hematological lineage has a
clear hierarchy and markers delineating
different stages of us so the
hematological stem cell which gives rise
to a lineage restricted progenitor and
that's differentiated but still has some
self renewal capacity and this gives
rise to further differentiated and loss
of self renewal renewal phenotypes but
this is actually this lineage is
disrupted in leukemia but it was with
hematological stem cell markers that the
first leukemic stem cells were
identified so what the authors showed
here in 1997 was was that the cd34
positive cd38 negative cells and they
actually got these from the bone marrow
of AML patients so there are primary
cells these cells could initiate tumors
in immunodeficient nod skid mice so that
covers one of the characteristics of
cancer stem cells the ability to
initiate tumors they also showed that
these cells had differentiation capacity
they found that the cells which they
transplanted with these markers 334 in
cd38 when these cells engrafted and were
tested six weeks later from the
xenograft models the bone marrow was
later analyzed and it actually
recapitulated the phenotype of the
original blast cells you can see the
percentages here of for example cd34 is
very similar from the original blast
cells to the engrafted ones which had a
different kind of stem like phenotype
so identification of stem cells cancer
stem cells in solid tumors has been a
bit more of a challenge because there
isn't always as clear a hierarchy
although for example here in the colon
identification of cancer stem cells is
helped by knowing the actual location of
the stem cells in the tissue so these
are here in the crypts there crypt
columnar cells so rare stem cells with
these markers can actually be identified
quite clearly in the tissue by
microscopy and then these markers can be
used to identify cancer stem cells this
has been done here on the right in
showing that CD 133 is a marker for
colon cancer stem cells this is a single
marker based identification of the
cancer stem cells and some studies since
may have used this marker in combination
with others to identify population with
similar characteristics I did have a
longer list on the couple of previous
slides of the colon cancer stem cell
markers but here anyway the CD under 33
cells cause tumor growth from much lower
numbers than the unsorted cells and even
the cd133 negative cells didn't grow
tumors at all and then when the cells
were grown under differentiate
differentiating media so addition of
serum and removal of some of the growth
factors EGF and fgf the cells which
differentiated we're not actually able
to grow tumors
so in the next example we the same
marker being used to identify gilma stem
cell so brain cancer stem cells this
paper was particularly significant in
demonstrating treatment resistant
characteristics and also identifying the
underlying mechanism for this in cancer
stem cells so it was fanfare seed a
radiation of the tumors and this tumors
from Mouse Senna grafts were enriched
for CD hundred and thirty three cells
third one hundred and thirty three
positive cells and a radiation of these
and the CD hundred and her three
negative cells demonstrated that the
cd133 positive cells retain greater
connie formation after radiation they
were still viable to grow the colonies
but then inhibition of checkpoint kinase
proteins by this DBH molecule prevented
the cells being able to activate DNA
damaged signaling and actually initiate
repair after radiation you can see that
almost no colonies grew in this
condition the CD under in territory
positive cells had lower apoptosis and
higher activation of various proteins in
the DNA damaged signaling response so
demonstrating that they have a greater
capacity to respond to DNA damage and
this results in even more efficient
repair and survival
so that is my introduction and
discussion of cancer stem cells in
general what the theory of cancer stem
cells is about and how cancer stem cells
are identified and then some of their
treatment resistance mechanisms so I'm
going to move on now to speak about
prostate cancer because as I said it's
actually been what I've been focusing on
for my PhD so this is part two of the
talk so prostate cancer is the most
common type of cancer in men in the UK
it's globally the third leading cause of
cancer-related death in men but it's
actually really difficult to find a
clearer statistic about the frequency of
prostate cancer mortality because
there's quite a complicated breakdown in
terms of the disease course so as you
can see from the diagram here the
majority of men are diagnosed with
localized prostate cancer that means
it's contained within the prostate gland
it may have includes up to stage 3 which
is extended beyond the prostate capsule
but this without significant lymph node
involvement and actually the survival
rate for this is really high over 90%
because the treatments for localized
prostate cancer are very effective so
radiation and surgery mainly and
prostate cancer development or
recurrence is measured by levels of the
prostate specific antigen which is
produced by the prostate and then
released into circulation so rising PSA
after successful localized treatment is
indicative of biochemical recurrence and
this really isn't uncommon it can occur
in up to 40% of men treated there's
slight variations between the type of
treatment they receive if it was surgery
or the radiation therapy however
biochemical recurrence doesn't actually
always lead to clinical progression so
at this stage the mortality rate is
still low because we have most of the
men being diagnosed essentially cured
successfully treated where early stage
prostate cancer and only some of them
are progressing to clinical progression
however kind of beyond that stage of
clinical progression the prognosis is
really poor and the mortality rate is
high so it's metastases
castrate resistance occurs in response
to engine treatment so engine treatment
is the oxygen decoration therapy is the
standard therapy for advanced prostate
cancer and resistance to this occurs in
a really high proportion of men like
almost all and after expected quite a
short amount of time of undergoing the
treatment so if this occurs castration
resistance and further metastasis the
treatment sorry the average survival is
only 1.5 years
so metastatic prostate cancer
essentially doesn't have a curative
therapy it's actually just
life-prolonging treatment and there's a
lot of research going on to develop new
therapies for for this to treat the
later stage but I think it's really
important to consider how an earlier
intervention could actually alter the
course of the disease
in other words preventing perhaps most
importantly clinical recurrence which is
where we consider that cut targeting
cancer stem cells comes in so back to
identifying the cancer stem cells what
do we know about prostate development
the cell types are the tissue lineage
because this will inform us as to how we
identify the cancer stem cells in the
prostate the prostate consists of basal
transit amplifying and luminal cells the
basal cells is where the stem cell
population resides and upper prostate
cancer itself actually has a
predominantly luminal phenotype and
that's what you would see on microscopy
staining of biopsies it's pretty much
all luminal cells many of this guides
are send towards the basal markers for
the identification of prostate cancer
cells
the first prostate cancer cells were
identified by this basal phenotype
profile cd44 positive alpha 2 beta 1
high integrins studies and cd133
positive cells so the cells with this
profile were shown to have greater
colony formation
Conny forming efficiency then transit
amplifying cells which are the ones in
the middle of that graph there which
don't express CD 133 but do Express CD
44 and the alpha beta integrins
and then the cells which are negative
for this these basal integrins on the
right of the graph there these are the
remaining population presented the
luminal cells you can see that they
don't really have any great colony
forming efficiency at all so in a
follow-up publication from the same
group they also showed that the prostate
cancer stem cells sustained much less
DNA damage which is shown here by gamma
histone h2ax staining and then compared
to the trans lamp Liffe eyeing the ta on
the graph and the CB so the committed
cells the CUDA differentiate itself and
a histone just histone deacetylase
inhibitor H stack inhibitor reversed the
radio radio resistance effect so this is
actually another demonstration then of
the mechanism of treatment resistance by
these cancer stem cells in prostate
cancer so the this this stopped previous
group so I'll just go back to this slide
a sec this group uses the model they use
primary prostate cancer cells derived
from biopsies from patients undergoing
primary from patients undergoing primary
treatment for prostate cancer surgeries
or prostatectomy removal of the prostate
and then you can get cells from the
biopsies but primary prostate cancer
cells are actually really difficult to
grow in vitro this is from personal
experience there there there's it's
quite confusing actually nobody really
has a very good answer as to why II
there they're difficult to grow so there
is a heavy reliance on prostate cancer
cell lines even though there are
actually only a few of these available
and these are all been isolated from
metastases so in contrast to the primary
cells which are turning from the
localized cancer the prostate cancer
cell lines are from metastases so that
is just something to consider that
different markers could be applicable in
different models so in this paper that
I'm discussing now they used the
functional marker all the idea jaja
needs and instead the D on for five
prostate cancer cell line but they did
similarly show that the aldehyde
dehydrogenase hai cells could initiate
tumors a lower frequency than the other
hydrogenase low cells and they showed
that in
they do have some primary samples as
well they should the aldehyde
dehydrogenase isoforms it's quite a
large family with lots of different
isoforms and it was nineteen these
either forms some of these were
upregulated in response to radiation so
this could represent enrichment in
response to radiation or possibly also a
protective response although actually
the signaling response of this group
identified in response to radiation was
that there was greater a KT - and
checkpoint - chk - signaling in the
aldehyde dehydrogenase hai cells so
proximity to the glioma stem cells that
I mentioned before these cancer stem
cells could have a more deficient sorry
efficient DNA damage signaling response
but here it was actually the wint
tgf-beta signaling that was crucial to
the radiation response and there was no
difference in tumor survival in mice in
algae in the aldehyde dehydrogenase hi
my Senna graft whether or not the
initiating cells were irradiated and non
irradiated didn't make a difference to
the mass survival whereas there was much
was a significant difference in increase
in survival in mice who were inoculated
where ad ated are hydrogenated low cells
so they were not really able to they
were much more affected by the radiation
so these two studies have dealt with
well the the first study dealt with
basal based identification of prostate
cancer stem cells and this city here
using aldehyde is kind of a phenotype
free perhaps sidestepping the issue of
pinning down the phenotype of the
prostate cancer stem cells but we have
been focusing on the basal cells of
being the source of stem cells in the
prostate however a number of more recent
studies have identified luminal prostate
cancer stem cells so firstly luminal
stem cells just from a healthy prostate
were identified so these these cells
were seen to have multipotent features
so when a prostate cells were isolated
from a biopsy and fractionated into
basil or luminal populations using cd4
t9f
base of population and CD 26 for the
luminal population both the basal and
luminal cells were capable of growing
organoids in justice defined media and
these organoids
actually expressed both basal and
luminal cytokeratins and also the
antigen receptor so each of the baseline
luminal cells was able to create to give
rise to a fully fully functional lineage
of cells so this finding really puts a
whole new spin on what's known about the
cell in lineage of the prostate it does
suggest a certain amount of plasticity
or even multiple lineages having
stemness capacity although the authors
did note in this paper that the luminal
cells had a much lower organoid growth
efficiency so it may still be that the
basal cells are the predominant cells of
the prostate but luminal cells may also
have this capacity then under certain
conditions so another group showed in a
mouse model of prostate cancer that a
small subset of cells expressing NK X
3-1 these cells didn't Express based on
markers but these were resistant to
castration so what we actually know
about the hierarchy of the prostate is
that we know what was originally
demonstrated by castration of rats in
which it was found that castration
caused regression of the luminal cells
but preservation of the basal cells so
castration was removing the androgen
signaling and then when the antigen
signaling was restored and this caused
regrowth of the prostate the luminal
cells were the ones regenerated so this
disc it gave you the idea - basal stem
cells give rise to luminal cells with
the growth stimulation from antigen so
the significance of this study is that
there are non basal cells surviving
castration and the study that also
showed that in a p10 knockouts at the
tumor suppressor on a genetic background
for the development of prostate cancer
in which the animal was castrated so
removing the luminal cells leaving the
NK X 3-1 cells that these cells were
drivers for cancer growth as well so
this or this paper actually suggested
that luminal cells could be the target
for transformation for prostate cancer
as well so these all show evidence
then that there can be baselet prostate
cancer cells with the phenotype cd44
alpha to be sure one integral hi-c
Dioner territory positive aldehyde hi
prostate cancer cells exist then there
are luminal prostate cancer stem cells
seen in this mouse model so actually in
my PhD I used a combination I used the D
on for five cell line and primary
samples from biopsies taken from
prostatectomy samples I grew these in
different media because the as I said
the primary cells are quite difficult to
grow so the media need a lot of
supplements for success of it so what
I'm kind of showing here is that these
these cells using using a cell line on
primary cells which by appearance by the
morphology here you can see they grew
quite differently they were under
different media conditions required this
to actually grow at the d1 4 5 s have
this what's known as a characteristic
cobblestone morphology while the primary
prostate cancer cells grew in a
morphology which I would say is more
similar to the original tissue they
didn't really grow in a flash uniform
sheath so these are two different models
in which the cells grew with a
characteristic appearance of either the
cell line or perhaps the original tissue
and I actually found a different
phenotype in in these cells so what I'm
suggesting kind of by showing these
different studies which have different
phenotypes to identify prostate cancer
stem cells under different conditions 2d
3d animal models is that the conditions
selected for the investigation of
prostate cancer stem cells can can by us
you towards having a different phenotype
in your in your experiments and that
this can result in in differences in in
identification identification of
prostate cancer stem cells because what
I saw here was that my d1 4 5 s had a
different phenotype to the primary
prostate cancer cells the d1 4 5 s were
as you can see over over two-thirds
basal cells so CD 49 s positive but
there was a double positive population
for CD 14 and F and CD 26 and I think
this suggests an intermediate popular
which may correspond to trans amplifying
cells but on the other hand my primary
prostate cells grew in with an almost
completely basal phenotype so for this
reason I didn't use a lineage specific
approach to isolating the cancer stem
cells
I used the functional marker are the
high D ajaja news and I was almost
surprised to find actually that the
aldehyde dehydrogenase high frequency of
population in the d1 4 5 and primary
prostate cancer cells was quite similar
proportions so so this could suggest
that the country stem cells in this
model this specific model do reside in
the basal compartment of the cells seen
as I had a similar aldehyde frequency in
the absence of the intermediate
phenotype in the primary cells but this
I think really emphasizes how
identifying quickly prostate cancer
cells and the markers used for this is
quite dependent on the conditions and
the model used so moving on to part 3 of
my talk we're going to be discussing how
cancer stem cells can be therapeutically
targeted so we have established that if
comes themselves are not specifically
treated or if a conventional treatment
that the cancer stem cells are resistant
to is unsuccessful in killing the cells
this can cause treatment recurrence so a
treatment for cancer stem cells then
must be able to kill them in a different
way that they might not be resistant to
and it must be specifically targeted so
that we know we're taking out the cancer
stem cells so this could be inhibition
of pathways intrinsic to cancer stem
cells like developmental signaling or by
immunotherapy targeting which is what
I'm going to focus on for the rest of
the talk so before I go get discussing
actually using the immune systems treat
cancer I do want to speak about why this
actually works in that Devine system is
capable of recognizing and killing
cancer so this this ongoing process is
described as the three e's of amino
addition so the immune system is capable
of controlling cancer development
and that's known as elimination however
if it isn't fully eliminated a pre
malignant growth may interact with you
system over time and this is known as
equilibrium this process can end in
elimination which is great or suggest
for genetic communicative variants and
aggressive growth so then escape
describes cancer growth which is a
failure of the immune system to contain
us so immune cells with an anti tumor
role includes cd8 and cd4 T cells and K
cells and inflammatory emeral
macrophages however in a tumor which is
escaped the immune system immune cells
could actually have a tumor promoting
effect which includes T regulatory cells
and m2 inflammatory macrophages
these cells inhibit inhibits actually
the tumour occurring immune response and
the tumor itself doesn't also have a
passive role in this process so it can
express inhibitory receptors produce
anti-inflammatory cytokines and this
makes it more difficult for the T cells
to respond by down-regulating
the tumors can also make it more
difficult for the T cells to respond by
down-regulating Antron expressions to
down-regulating HLA expression levels so
immunotherapy then aims to introduce or
boost a tumor killing response by
engaging the anti-tumor immune cells
that I mentioned or actually by blocking
some of the inhibitory signals so
confirming the therapy with science
magazines brighter of the year in 2013
and I'm sure most of you will have heard
how the discoveries relating to the
mechanism of action of checkpoint
inhibitors was awarded the Nobel Prize
last year these are the main types of
immunotherapy the checkpoint inhibitors
refer to blocking some of the immune
inhibitory signals I mentioned and these
I would say in particular are at the
forefront of the promising results
around immunotherapy but also there are
many other areas so monoclonal
antibodies are being used more and more
as receptor agonists or antagonists in
crucial cancer signaling pathways
vaccines are being developed for example
which engage dendritic cells to provide
the required signals of an immune
response and direct it towards a cancer
antigen but on the subject of cancer
antigens I'm going to focus today on
adoptive t-cell immunotherapy as that is
what I have been investigating during my
PhD
so cd8 t-cells
are the killer cells of the adopters
immune system so they kill cells in an
antigen specific way by releasing
effector molecules perforin and
granzymes into the target cell and
activating death receptor signaling T
cells are capable of rapidly
proliferating when they're activated so
a large number of T cells can respond to
an antigen simulus also in immunotherapy
this activation and Co stimulation might
actually be done ex vivo so by maybe
extracting the cells in the patient or
modifying cells from healthy donors
because the correct stimulation
activation response is often disrupted
in cancer and the natural course of a
t-cell response in the body includes the
persistence of antigen specific memory T
cells and I would say while this hasn't
been sort of demonstrated that the
persistence of memory having been shown
in an experimental condition it is
actually suggested to be one of the main
reasons for the durability of responses
observed with this form of the you know
therapy so really importantly T cells
can respond to an enormous range of
intracellular and cell surface proteins
by recognizing the short fragments of
the protein known as antigens which are
presented in context for HLA at the
surface of the cell and identifying
tumor associated antigens is one of the
main focuses of T cell immunotherapy and
this can be done by predictive or
experimental methods so examples of
these predictive methods DNA library
screening involves large-scale cloning
and production of proteins from patient
samples and immunological so either
antibody or t-cell screening of proteins
for an activation response so a number
of prominent clinical targets have been
identified in this way for example at NY
ESO Mart one major one and then an
alternative way is using reverse
immunology which involves in silico
prediction of antigens using algorithms
and these algorithms can actually
predict pretty much the course of a
proteins journey to antigen presentation
including protease Omer processing top
transport and
HLA binding although it does have the
downside that it might not actually
identify sort of the most immuno genic
antigens there's not really any way of
knowing how immuno genic your antigen is
until you go and test it in an
experimental condition but at this web
link then is is one of the ones I've
used quite commonly different this this
webpage has different algorithms for
testing these different aspects of
predicting antigen binding but antigens
can also be identified experimentally by
capturing them in complex with HLA from
the cell surface and then uncovering the
epitope sequence by mass spectrometry
this is known then as immuno peptide all
mix or h layla genome analysis and this
is what i've mostly done during my PhD
so the way this is done is that antigens
are captured by onedah precipitation of
the HLA complexes from the surface of
the cells and this can be sort of
tailored to a specific HLA allele if you
have the antibody against that allele
are actually broadened to include
capture of an EI chael a class 1 antigen
on the surface of the cell this area is
really growing because it enables novel
antigen discovery this really
interesting paper that i'm referring to
here is about machine learning to
improve antigen prediction from real
real mass spectrometry data sets and
then this can all help increase our
understanding of antigen processing when
analyzing the data sets which can
feedback into improving predictive
methods so the hatred a ligand or
analysis in this example here was used
to identify a cancer stem cell antigen
in colon cancer so this group actually
established a contra stem cell line by
repeated cloning of site population
cells from colon cancer cell line so
site population cells but sort of the
sort of functional assays for cancer
stem cells because these cells have
highly active ABC transporters which if
looks the hoist die so it's a it's a
functional method for isolating the
cancer stem cells so HLA like an ohm
analysis of
by populations for the cancer stem cells
or main populations so nany focusing our
non stem cancer cells didn't reveal
differences in antigen presentation
including this one that they've
identified here the iv9 peptide of the
ASB 4 genes so this peptide was actually
found exclusively in the HLA ligand Dome
of the site population or colon cancer
stem cells compared to the main
population so a T cell phone was
developed which responded to the iv9
peptide po cells with little off target
specificity up in the kind of top line
here the graph a on the top row and
these cells actually preferentially
killed fly population cells in be
they're the specific consciousness or
targeting then in in vivo model
investigating tumor control and adoptive
t-cell immunotherapy essentially these
IV nine specific t-cells were capable of
presenting tumor growth actually whether
given prior or after a tumor challenge
so I was really lucky to have the
opportunity to collaborate with a group
to produce this paper there from Safra
Medical University in Japan and with
them I carried those HL a ligand Dom
analysis to identify novel prostate
cancer stem cell antigens we did have a
bit of a different approach we we didn't
establish a cancer stem cell clonal line
this is quite time-consuming and
definitely a challenge to maintain a
pure and stable clonal stem line so what
we did instead was we analyzed the Duan
for prostate cancer cell line the whole
population and then we identified cancer
stem cell specific antigens based on the
gene expression of the antigens in
sorted aldehyde dehydrogenase high or
low cells so I was saying that the
aldehyde dehydrogenase marker was the
one I used during during my PhD project
to identify the prostate cancer stem
cells so we perform PCR of some of the
genes of interest corresponding to the
antigens and looked at the ones which
were more highly expressed in the
aldehyde dehydrogenase high cells so we
identified these
targets as I said in the deal one four
five cells but actually we did also see
because I was using primary prostate
cancer cells as well we looked at which
antigens had a higher key expression in
the aldehyde dehydrogenase high primary
prostate cancer samples so these are
actually the graphs that are shown here
so the graph on the left is demonstrate
sort of my cancer stem cell specific
antigens of interest and the graph on
the right is what we designated shared
antigens for which the gene expression
was was not different exactly between
the aldehyde dehydrogenase high in low
cells but it was there was a high
abundance of the gene transcripts in the
PCR analysis because we felt that these
would be a relevant target being high
high gene expression hopefully high
protein turnover and presentation at the
cell surface so still being a relevant
target for both cancer stem cells and
non-stem cancer cells and in any case we
also felt that from a sort of
translational point of view that an
antigen based immunotherapy is probably
more likely to succeed by targeting
multiple antigens and preventing the
possibility of antigen escape variants
so my final work in my PhD has been on
the isolation of t-cells which recognize
these antigens and perhaps
unsurprisingly the frequency of T cells
responses to the cancer stem cell
antigen was really very low but I have
actually been able to expand these cells
quite a bit with the goal of developing
a clonal t salt line I was also very
lucky to have a donor that was the
correct HLA HLA type which is B 50 which
is in do you want professor Lane it is a
lesser common HLA type but I was very
lucky to have a healthy donor who is the
correct HLA type and the shared antigen
that I mentioned on the previous slide
on the right here so gene number 3 or
antigen number 3 this is identified from
the d1 for 5 cells so it was a B 50 H
lady 50 epitope however it isn't
actually what I eventually isolated T
cells against you can see I have a H lay
a 2 donor here so actually when we
modelled
the b---fifty epitope interactions in
Hawaii no homology modeling design we
found that I didn't really have
particularly optimal interactions in the
HLA binding pocket so instead we
identified a hate relay a two epitope
from the same protein and if they had a
much higher abundance of HLA to donors
to to test and we were actually able to
decide which donors to use to develop
the T cell lines from because we had as
you can see here quite a good response
from this particular donor
so there are lots of other studies
investigating immunity are getting of
cancer stem cells which have progressed
to in vivo models and look very
promising
an example here is in prostate cancer
where this group developed care t-cells
targeting the cell membrane protein up
come this is a car t-cell so it's a
different approach to adoptive t-cell
therapy it's against surface antigen or
surface proteins sorry so AM non h ly
restricted or presented antigens is
actually a protein which is expressed on
the cell surface so that car t-cells
were tested against Jenna graphed tumors
initiated by two different prostate
cancer cell lines so the first one had
widespread and hyep calm expression or
the and the other one actually had a
rarer population of outcome expressing
cells and the car T cells were effective
at controlling tumor growth in the high
F Comics pressing model which was great
and very exciting but even more
interestingly the care T cells were able
to prevent metastases in vivo just by
targeting the smaller proportion of
Epcon expressing cells in the pc3 model
the pc3 prostate cancer cell line which
was used in the xenograph models shown
here so the alternative one was a
different pc3 related cell line with the
higher F calm expression but shown here
is the ones with much lower outcome
expression as you can see here there's
very low metastasize over time so there
is good good tumor control from these
car T cells
another study then here targets
targeting cancer stem cell antigen was
actually done by adoptive cd8 t-cell
immunotherapy and this was targeting an
epitope of aldehyde dehydrogenase this
study looked at a couple of cancer type
models including shown here had a neck
cancer breast cancer and pancreatic
cancer the aldehyde epitope was
identified in a previous study by mass
spectrometry analysis of peptides eluted
from to realize it's from a head and
neck cancer patient and as you can see
here the T cells developed to recognize
this antigen were capable of reducing
tumor growth in the head and neck cancer
model and also greatly improved survival
in a lung cancer metastases model of
breast cancer and these show that as
well as identifying novel antigens for
cancer stem cell therapy like in the
previous studies my own work and the
previous studies that I showed targeting
antigens which are identified from just
cancer stem cell protein markers this
can also be an effective therapeutic
approach although I will say that
management of off target effects in
using the same markers of healthy cancer
stem cells as the immunotherapy is
actually a really important in fact
factor to control against so if the
markers used are common to healthy cells
you do want to make sure that the T
cells don't go off and target them and
cause undesirable side effects so I'm
summarizing now I hope I've shown you
today that immunotherapy of cancer stem
cells is viable and effective approach
in preclinical models
I think cancer stem cell immunotherapy
is actually also reaching early stage
clinical trials so it's a really
promising and exciting area of cancer
research so summarizing here cancer stem
cells are the main drivers of tumor
growth are present in most forms of
cancer and they are important targeted
targets this is particularly relevant in
prostate cancer to prevent recurrence
and progression to insurable disease
immunotherapy which is being widely
tested in the mentor for cancer
treatment represents a way in which
cancer stem cells can be treated in a
specific manner that they might not be
resistant to and treating cancer stem
cells by T cell immunity
requires identification of antigens and
a really effectively an early effective
way of doing this is by immuno peptide
or mix and I did this in my project I
used the HLA like UNAM analysis to
identify prostate cancer stem cell
antigens and we can see then other
studies have also demonstrated effective
outcomes in preclinical models of cancer
stem cell immunotherapy so these are my
references I've referenced a lot of
really interesting studies and I'm sure
there are other many other publications
in this area that I haven't been able to
include for reasons of time constraint
so and last and most importantly really
are my acknowledgments so I've been
really lucky to have had excellent
supervision during my PhD in particular
I am really grateful for all the time
invested by my primary supervisor
Susanna and also Steve's in push I've
had the opportunity to collaborate with
so many people with such an amazingly
wide range of expertise and which are
right on my doorstep in Cardiff
University as I said I performed the
like gnome analysis in collaboration
with Sapporo medical university I was
hosted there very generously in 2017 my
PhD is funded by the Welsh cancer
charity ten of us and for the trip to
Japan I also received support from the
Great Britain Sassicaia Foundation and
my primary prostate cancer work samples
were made possible by the Wales cancer
bank so thank you again to turma Fisher
and lab roots and Alex will the previous
speakers for nominating me some of my
social media details are here too so I'm
happy to discussing further via these
channels and I am happy also to continue
taking questions now thank you
thank you Amy for that informative
presentation we'll now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions that
we have time for okay let's get started
Amy our first question is targeting
antigens that are specific to cancer
stem cells or shared in both cancer stem
cells and non skin cancer cells likely
to be better therapeutically put we
approach so that's a good question and
as I said we did look at the two
possibilities or we identified two
different either cancer stem cell
specific or shared antigens so there's
the group that I work to actually have a
publication discussing this and the
group in Japan and they do kind of
speculate that if you have T cells which
are specific for a cancer stem cell
antigen I teach that T cell clone in a
therapeutic situation there would be a
better effector to target ratio to to
eliminate the cancer stem cells than
comparable having the same one T cell
clone which would have to deal with both
non-stem cancer cells and cancer stem
cells if it was a shared antigen and
they do they do think that it might be
better to to have the the higher
effector to target ratio however a
overall more effective therapeutic
approach would probably be to have
different T cell clones dealing with
both elements or you know combine a
therapy which otherwise eradicate the
non-stem cancer cells like for example
radiation therapy or some of the more
other personalized therapies see I hope
that answers the question
yes thank you Amy now next question how
early is um let's see how early is it
possible to diagnose prostate cancer
with proposed method
um so what I really discussed here is
more of a treatment method than a
diagnosis method the standard ways of
diagnosing prostate cancer they include
PSA monitoring so the prostate specific
antigen that that I did sort of briefly
refer to as a monitoring for recurrence
that's also used to it's not rolled out
typically in screening globally but it's
used as a monitoring method to be
roughly predictive of prostate cancer
and prostate cancer that is ultimately
diagnosed by a biopsy as to a treatment
method ideally we would believe that it
will be most effective to be able to
treat cancer stem cells in a primary
therapeutic approach in order to prevent
relapse oh they said it's quite a highly
prevalent problem in prostate cancer
however it would of course still be
relevant and needed really to find an
immunotherapy which treats metastatic
prostate cancer currently there's only
one licensed hair therapy for metastatic
prostate cancer called super cell T so
if if the cancer stem cells cancer stem
cell clone is also metastases initiating
it would certainly be relevant to target
to test anyway in the first instance
cancer stem cells specific T cell
immunity for metastatic prostate cancer
but it would be still very important and
I think to consider sort of the clinical
approach of not over treating which as
it is is sort of a bit of a problem and
prostate cancer to try and predict the
patients who are going to progress and
have the metastatic aggressive disease
which is the main reason we would want
to be actually we would be trying to
prevent that or to treat it
thank you Amy our next question do you
grow the primary cells hypoxic
conditions no we don't that's a really
good question and it's very relevant
because there's a loss of kind of
research into the cancer stem cell niche
and I think I probably alluded to it a
bit in my talk by saying that sometimes
different markers might be more relevant
for different cell lines different media
conditions hypoxia is a very relevant
one condition for cancer stem cells
because they are taught to sort of
thrive actually in a hypoxic niche and
unfortunately I simply didn't have
access to the infrastructure to to grow
myself in a hypoxic niche but it would
be definitely very relevant to look into
that in future investigations
Camie we have time for just a few more
questions our next question is the
discovery and targeting of cancer stem
cell antigens applicable to other types
of cancer yeah yeah for sure it is like
so I did refer to the one in colon
cancer in the presentation it has been
done in a couple of other types of
cancer from from the point of view of
novel antigens as opposed to just
knowing what the known consciousness of
markers are and deriving antigens from
them like the other paper that I
mentioned for a bahai dehydrogenase so
it's actually been done in a couple more
by ligand dome analysis in AML CML and
also quite recently in glioblastoma and
I can probably provide some references
there if there's further interested not
we have time for one more question and I
want to remind our audience that many
questions we did not have time to get to
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
now Amy do you feel the primary cells
capture the heterogeneity of the cancer
you described better than the cell line
to a certain extent yes I think so so
from the morphology I don't know how
clear it was really the image in my
slide but certainly I would think in the
morphology point here the the primary
cells definitely in appearance grew in
in what looked like more reminiscent of
sort of the slices of biopsy that you
would see as opposed to just been a more
homogeneous flat adherence to the
plastic of the D one four five cells
they also had a much shorter lifespan so
they weren't they weren't immortalized
they grew for kind of eight or nine
passages at most and I did also find
that there would be fire blasts growing
out and so obviously they do actually
retain some plasticity there but then
again you know from from the phenotype
that I showed
neither of these cells did manage to
grow to have an Illumina cells present
which would be the predominant form of
of cells in prostate cancer so you know
it's still I would still acknowledge
that it's not exactly a perfect model
there either but at the same time we
found with the basal sort of guidance
that are the heighth dehydrogenase
phenotype sort of a little bit like I
said from from one of the other papers
sites having slightly the phenotype
issue that we were able to still find
aldehyde dehydrogenase high cells which
I did confirm in a couple of other
assets that they had some cancer stem
cell characteristics
thank you Amy do you have any final
comments for our audience
no I don't think so thank you everyone
for attending and listening and please
do feel free to reach out if you have
any further interest in the area some of
my social media handles there and now
that's it thank you thanks so much
a big thank you again to Aimee clawed
for her time today and her important
research we would also like to thank
laborat
and our sponsors Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through july 2019 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye